you
hi my name is Melissa Hendershot and I'm
a graduate student at UCSF today I'm
here with Chris Garcia who's a professor
and Howard Hughes Medical Investigator
at Stanford University chris is a
dedicated professor but he also spent
thousands of hours training for and
running ultra marathons so welcome Chris
thanks for joining us thank you first of
all can you just tell us a little bit
about what an ultra marathon is and what
that entails technically an ultra
marathon is any distance race longer
than a marathon so ultra marathons can
be anything from fifty kilometers which
is a pretty popular distance 200 miles
and you know they're races in between 50
mile or hundred K's
so that's that's what defines an ultra
marathon when did you first start
running seriously well I was always an
athlete I was a tennis player growing up
a pretty serious tennis player and then
in graduate school I started running and
I started running marathons in the East
Coast and actually wrote a single scull
for a while when I was in graduate
school and then when I moved to
California for my postdoc I started
getting more serious about running and
doing triathlons and and I did a lot of
triathlons when I was in San Diego for
my postdoc at Scripps and you know I'd
always heard about ultra marathons and
I'd always had a predilection for
distance and and so and I knew that
ultra marathons were a big thing in the
Bay Area but you know like 15 years ago
when I was just hearing about them they
weren't as popular as they are now so it
was kind of an urban myth you know these
races where people would run a hundred
miles and and and so that's you know and
so that I felt like that was something
that I could potentially be decent at
and it kind of escalated from there
what was your first ultra so my first
ultra was actually a postdoc in my lab
had had run some ultras and and she got
me to sign up with her to run a race and
the Marin Headlands called the Marin 50k
and it's through the headlands and it
was through the trails and it was just
it was just a it was almost like an
out-of-body experience it was just you
know running through the fog over there
and along the coastal trail and through
the then through the the rain forests
and it was from the first time I ever
did it it was just that was it
I was hooked and that was you know
almost 12 years ago how many ultra
marathons have you done do you know yeah
I've done a total of 80 80 or 82 or
something like that and amongst those 80
some races I think I've run like 1,300
miles probably 25 or 30 50 miles and ten
or so hundred K's and then a lot of 50k
so kind of you know the very long
distance races you run fewer of this
your body just can't take that many how
do you train for their races so during
the week I don't you know I do normal
distances you know I'll run six or seven
miles maybe four to four times a week
and actually do a lot of cross-training
I swim a lot I swim with Stanford
master's team a lot in the mornings and
I also cycle a lot and so I have like
the 25 mile loop I do to get to work
just to sort of take the pounding off my
body
but then on weekends there's there's
usually a long Saturday run that's
anywhere from 20 to 30 miles with a
group of people I've been running with
for a long time they're they're great
friends and a big part of why I'm doing
this and that that's a you know
saturday-morning staple and then as
we're sort of ramping up into races and
now you'll back it up again on Sunday
with maybe like a 15 or 20
run so the key to doing ultras the long
run and the long run can be anywhere
from twenty to forty miles and then
backing it up with the long run the next
day and so it comes in large chunks you
know and so for me going into a hundred
mile er
you know I might max out it like an 80
or 90 mile week for a few weeks but
average total maybe 60 or 70 miles a
week some people run a hundred and fifty
miles a week you know the real the real
elite ultra runners you know will run a
100 150 200 miles a week some people can
get away with less and so it's a very
individual thing how do you manage to
push yourself past the feelings of
discomfort and unhappiness yeah that's a
good question you just keep going you
know you realize you know when you first
start doing these races you really doubt
what you can do and and and you fear
failure and and but then with enough
experience you realize that you can get
passed through those those bad patches
when you're when you're just completely
you just can't go on that you can you
know if you understand your nutrition
well enough you know how to manage
yourself hydrate yourself and you know
you have the confidence you've gone
those longer distances before you can
push yourself through it and you recover
it's amazing in these races how many
times you you you go to complete failure
and you recover and then you're running
along just as if you started running you
know ten minutes ago and and so it's a
constant sort of cycle of ups and downs
in these races what sorts of things do
you think about when you're running you
know it's interesting um well you know
when I'm running just for for for
training or you know in the afternoon
here at Stanford and like out here I'm
usually thinking about problems in the
lab science projects issues with people
managing projects but then when you run
far enough you your your mind goes blank
and you don't really think about
anything you just kind of you don't have
enough glucose in your brain to think
and
and you know people ask me you know what
do you think about during 100-mile race
when you're out there for a day do you
get bored and it's amazing how fast
these things go I mean I barely remember
anything that happens in these races you
know you're just kind of in survival
mode and you're thinking about managing
yourself and your nutrition and and so
you're just you're so in the moment and
you're not thinking about anything else
except just you know maximizing you know
how well how good you feel have you ever
had a scientific breakthrough moment
while you've been out running on the
trail yeah actually a lot of them I've
had a lot of ideas for projects usually
usually early in the run and I remember
very distinctly when I was an assistant
professor we we were trying to solve a
crystal structure that had a very
complex packing and symmetry problem and
you know we were banging on the thing
for a week or two and and well the
project took longer than that but but
once we had phases we know we were
staring at the graphics and we couldn't
figure out the symmetry of the thing and
and I took a run around Stanford tonight
and I and I solved the problem in my
head it just came to me you know it just
kind of percolate it up and so you know
stuff like that happens all the time how
have you found ways to balance having
both a demanding profession and a pretty
demanding hobby
well I'm very disciplined with my time
and I I don't have a lot of free time
I'm I'm usually doing one of two things
I'm either working or I'm I'm out
training and you know I I get up at 4:00
in the morning and I'm I I work for a
while and then I swim and then usually
you know then I go to work and then I go
to lab and and then later in the
afternoon I usually do another training
session and then go back to lab and then
go home and I don't get a lot of sleep
and
I enjoy it I mean I love it I love I
love the immersion you know I love my
life and and and there's not a lot of
there's not a lot of tolerant you know
the tolerances are pretty fine between
the stuff I'm doing and I always feel
like it's on the verge of blowing up but
but I feel very fortunate you know
there's so much there's so many things I
want to do that
you know there's it's difficult to find
enough time in the day often do you see
any parallels between running ultra
marathons and running a lab or any
skills that you've acquired through your
racing that have helped you as a P I
definitely it's been hugely enormous ly
helpful I mean just athletics in general
has a lot of lessons to learn about
doing science you know and and you know
there's a physicality to science that I
think people tend to underestimate that
you know you need to be able to push
yourself through barriers to keep going
on hard scientific problems and ultra
teaches a lot of lessons about humility
and stoicism staying within oneself and
and being in the moment it's had a great
pacifying influence on me for sure and
also having the long view you know
science when you if you're working on
hard scientific problems or any sort of
important scientific problem it's
generally going to be a long-term
problem and and you have to have the
patience and the foresight to understand
that the payoff is in the future it's in
the distance and it's also in the
process of doing the science it's not
just in the reward so ultra has I think
the same kinds of lessons to teach that
about about you know enjoying the
process learning learning from the
process and and having the long view and
having the confidence that you can get
there if you just persist
you